[Music]
on this Sunday night high seas treaty
the historic and high-stakes deal to
safeguard international waters the ship
has reached the shore
plus global warming and National
Security the dire warning from Canada's
spy agency
a wave of suspected schoolgirl
poisonings Sparks widespread protests in
Iran
who could be responsible and why to roam
or not to Rome corporations are using
inflation as an excuse to pass on higher
prices the data roaming decision and
price rise dropping this week
and the dream come true for a Toronto
nine-year-old spinning her way to
success
global national with Fara Nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with a moment more
than 15 years in the making after years
of negotiations nearly 200 Nations have
made history signing the high seas
treaty it's illegally binding pact to
protect International oceans the
framework aims to place 30 percent of
the global ocean under protection by
2030. right now only 1.2 percent of the
ocean is protected Redmond Shannon has
our top story tonight on a deal being
called world changing
way out to sea away from civilization
there is often little or no protection
for marine life but that may soon change
the ship has reached the
a rare moment of international consensus
Nations agreeing on the landmark text of
a high seas treaty some Canadian
environmental groups were among those
observing at the United Nations
Headquarters following years of
negotiations I did shed some tears as
did many people in the room
um it's it's it's it's powerful when the
world comes together to agree to do
something that we need to do which is
really act more quickly on protecting
biodiversity the high seas are Waters
Beyond National Economic Zones currently
just one percent of these seas are
protected the treaty aims to increase
that to 30 percent by 2030 including
areas like the so-called lost city in
the Mid-Atlantic it's got unique
hydrothermal fans boiling water very
unusual
usual and right now it now is protected
and interest potentially to deep sea
mining any mining in the high seas would
be subject to stricter environmental
assessments the treaty also aims to
control the effects of shipping and
overfishing what we see is this
increased activity on the ocean
including in international waters and
and it's becoming uh very intense and
the impacts will be being felt very far
from sure and very deep as ever one of
the main sticking points was money
poorer Nations wanted to prevent richer
countries from hoarding the profits from
any medical or scientific discoveries in
the high seas at least 60 National
governments must now legally ratified
the treaty developing countries will get
legal aid to help make that happen we'd
like to see Canada step up to
there I think that that's going to be
really important after ratification the
real hard work of implementing the
treaty begins conservationists say that
can't come soon enough Redmond Shannon
Global News London
and there's a stark warning about
climate change from Canada's Spy Service
csis says climate change poses a
profound ongoing threat to National
Security and prosperity the newly
released analysis from 2021 obtained by
the Canadian press spells out several
concerns it warns the arctic's receding
ice coverage will allow for routine
navigation of the Northwest Passage and
the extraction of resources and this
could increase the risk of Russian
military activity and a growing Chinese
presence in the area the brief also
foresees an increase in violent
extremism from people who want to speed
up climate change Solutions
there have been more avalanches in BC
Backcountry Following last week's deadly
slide near invermir that killed three
German Nationals during a heli skiing
trip
yesterday three more Avalanches came
down near Pemberton north of Vancouver
trapping two skiers in separate slides
each person was dug out by their
respective ski Partners before being
airlifted to hospital suffering severe
injuries
and those series of slides follow what's
been an extremely active and deadly
Avalanche season in BC 12 people have
been killed this year alone in the
province the latest deadly Avalanche was
last Wednesday in In Vermeer which
claimed the lives of three German
tourists
there was another battle over
transgender rights in Calgary this
weekend with two opposing rallies over
drag events
[Applause]
hundreds showed up to stand in
solidarity with transgender people while
celebrating drag story time events at
libraries there were counter protesters
as well a smaller rally opposing those
events and trans people using change
rooms believing they harm children
there are growing concerns as well for
historic safe spaces that are meant for
members of Canada's lgbtq plus Community
across the country places like gay bars
or whole villages in many cities are
slowly Vanishing especially in the face
of gentrification and as Heather York's
West explains this troubling Trend
couldn't come at a worse time when the
community has been increasingly coming
under attack
Mark Campbell has opened up his bar
every afternoon for decades but soon the
Backlot in Calgary may have to go dark
for good I've got a termination of these
back in first of November this block is
up for redevelopment there's going to be
a 20-story condor development they want
to build here known as the cheers of
Calgary gay community the back lot is
one of only three
lgbtq2s plus bars left in the city yeah
we've been losing various spaces in
Calgary for years back Boys Town was was
next door here detour Arena was on 17th
what you're seeing is the processes of
what could be described as
gentrification the development of of
real estate the development of condos in
particular parts of of cities it's
happening in communities across the
country hanlon's Point Beach on Toronto
Island was one of Canada's oldest queer
spaces it's been used as a Gathering
Place for more than 80 years but its
future as a safe space was also recently
under threat when the city announced
plans to build a nearby concert venue
thousands of new people who would be
arriving at the space could create
opportunities for conflict and
discrimination and even violence it's a
valid fear with threats against the
queer community on the rise drag events
in several North American cities have
had to be canceled or postponed we're
actually at a time where there's a new
right-wing attack upon especially drag
performances but also trans people and
queer people and queer youth in
particular
it really shows that we have still have
a long way to go and so these kinds of
places are still needed
public outcry the city of Toronto this
week dropped its plans for the concert
venue near hanlon's Point Beach a safe
space preserved for now in one city as
advocates in another city hope to do the
same Heather urac's West Global News
Calgary
to Iran next were a growing number of
schoolgirls are falling ill in a
mysterious wave of alleged poisonings
the Iranian regime is finally
acknowledging samples it had collected
are suspicious it blames Hardline
islamist groups opposed to girls
education but as Taria Israel reports
some believe the regime itself may be to
blame
this scene keeps playing out across Iran
school girls arriving at hospitals
disoriented and struggling to breathe in
music first we smelled gas in the
classroom says this student then people
became dizzy one by one they became sick
after noxious fumes wafted through the
classroom the so far unexplained illness
has hit hundreds of girls in 50 schools
throughout the country it's not clear
what substance is making them sick we
are not 100 percent is just related to
the gas attack or not
still is under the investigation as I
said because there's no transparency in
the Iran's regime the regime initially
dismissed the cases when they began in
November and only now is vowing to
investigate
the interior Minister has assigned what
he calls a special committee admitting
some of the samples collected are
suspicious Tehran has blamed opponents
of girls education and also the
country's enemies accusing them of
inciting panic but women's rights
activists suspect it's an act of
Retribution from the regime itself this
is the reality of Islamic Republic
against women and then what's happening
reason is is that clearly they are
taking Revenge
young women have been at the Forefront
of anti-government protests sweeping the
country
they began after the death of Masa amini
killed in Iranian custody after she was
arrested for not wearing her hijab
properly
the apparent poisonings have sparked
more protests from Desperate parents who
say they're being silenced
video posted on social media appears to
show Iran's revolutionary guard pulling
them into a white van the Iranian regime
is also once again cracking down on
citizens demanding their human rights
and fundamental freedoms the U.S says
more than 500 Iranians have been killed
Crackdown
country where women and girls are coming
increasingly under attack
tariya isri Global News
Ottawa
in Ukraine Russian troops are still
trying to encircle the flashpoint city
of buckmoon so far Moscow has been
unsuccessful in doing that but Russian
forces are slowly closing in
Ukraine's military more than 130 attacks
have been repelled in the last day alone
keeve says it has managed to fend off
fresh waves of Russian assaults but with
most of the city reduced to rubble and
with the supply routes narrowing
Ukraine's command has signaled it will
likely withdraw rather than risk being
surrounded
and what's happening in Ukraine is top
of mind for estonians heading to the
pool today to pick that country's next
leader the votes pitting one of Europe's
staunchest supporters of Ukraine against
a far-right party prime minister Kaya
kalas has constantly called for fresh
sanctions against Moscow and is favored
to win a second term she's being
challenged by estonia's populist
opposition party which is trying to
capitalize on anger surrounding Rising
living costs and also stopping the
intake of Ukrainian refugees thousands
of people are without Shelter tonight in
Southeastern Bangladesh after a massive
fire ripped through a crowded rohingya
refugee camp
the fire erupted just before 3 P.M local
time and it quickly tore through around
2 000 shelters at Cox's bizarre Camp
leaving an estimated 12 000 refugees
homeless most of whom escaped
persecution in neighboring Myanmar 35
mosques and 21 Learning Centers were
also destroyed before the fire was put
out there are no reports of any
casualties and the cause of the fire is
still under investigation
the new study that can make a big
difference in dementia rates coming up
the vitamin supplement that may lower
your risk
foreign
vitamin that you probably already have
in your medicine cabinet could help
prevent dementia a study done between
researchers in Calgary and in the UK
show that taking vitamin D could be part
of the solution as Carolyn Curry de
Castillo reports a national project is
being launched to get more insight
Frank sangier has been caring for his
wife for four years she was diagnosed
with dementia he says it's hard to
describe what it's like to watch the
person you love change dramatically and
no it's not getting any better what do
you find is most challenging I would say
managing sadness a new study done over
the course of 10 years found in those
who were taking vitamin D there was
about a 40 percent lower rate for
development of dementia researchers also
found that the effects were greater in
those with normal cognition than in
those with mild cognitive impairment
suggesting the earlier you start the
more you can prevent progression we have
had 20 years of drug failures in in
dementia and one of the consistent
themes is that we're we're intervening
too late Dr zanor Ismail at the
University of Calgary says vitamin D
research on people who already have
dementia showed mixed results likely
because by the time you have dementia
it's pretty late in the course and a big
issue in the whole field is that we are
detecting it too late Dr Ismail is
leading the can protect project that
launched on Wednesday aimed at getting
more insight into the brain as people
age anyone over 40 can join the online
study researchers say it will provide
invaluable information on which risk
factors are the best targets for
preventing dementia the earlier the
better I always say that the prevention
starts in childhood and developing a
robust brain there is currently no cure
for dementia and there are gaps in our
knowledge of it we know the consequences
but we don't know what to cause what
caregivers are encouraged to take part
in the can protect study I think we're a
number of years away but if this is a
path you know that's good it's worth
contributing to UFC researchers say
preventing Dementia or even delaying its
onset is critical given the growing
numbers of people affected Carol and
Curry de Castillo Global News
I had planning a trip the two telecom
companies raising your roaming rates
this week
traveling with your cell phone is about
to get more expensive for some Canadians
both Telus and Bell have announced price
increases for roaming starting this week
the daily rate will go up by at least a
dollar as Shauna Shea reports critics
say it's another gouge for Canadians who
don't have many choices left when it
comes to wireless carriers
Canadians are already used to paying
more for mobile phone service than those
in many other countries now the price is
going up for those using phones out of
the country corporations are using
inflation as an excuse to pass on higher
prices both Telus and Bell are raising
daily prices for those who use their
phones outside Canada not a lot more
about a dollar a day starting next week
the companies will soon charge between
13 and 16 dollars a day expert for phone
use in the U.S and other International
destinations this former Bell customer
says it's too much I absolutely think
it's a cash grab I noticed that when I
went down to Florida over Christmas
use my emails through free Wi-Fi
consumers in Canada don't have a lot of
choice but we have even less Choice when
we're abroad Bell and tell us didn't
respond to interview requests but as we
stood outside one Toronto Bell store to
interview customers this bill manager
named Jason came up to us telling us we
shouldn't be standing in the public
sidewalk blocking the Bell sign about
authorizing being recorded right now I'm
not authorizing don't touch don't touch
the camera don't put it in the face
please I'm standing on the sidewalk sir
you've come out to talk to us and we're
standing on the sidewalk sir
what's the problem some customers told
us they aren't making enough effort to
get a better deal I I'm guilty of that
just taking what's you know what they
give me I take others say they'll get a
local phone provider when they travel in
future yeah I would get a SIM card and
just use it with my phone that I already
had I would just get a burner and tell
people this is my number cheaper choices
when high phone prices in this country
are getting higher Charlotte Global News
she's a three-time world record holder
and she's only nine next we're going to
speak with a Toronto student who is just
getting started with her big dreams
[Music]
a young girl from Ontario has got plenty
to brag about lately after hooping her
way to not one not two but three World
Records all the practice has paid off
for a moment even North a nine-year-old
hula hooper from Mississauga she was in
London earlier this year where she set
records for multiple and pretty
difficult hula hoop techniques Landing
her response in the upcoming Book of
Guinness World Records and I'm very
pleased to have mammothy join us now
thanks so much for joining us first of
all three different records tell us
about these three different ones
um so I all of them I've combined
gymnastics and hula hoop to do it so my
first record
was the most hula hoop rotations in the
knees well in in landscapes and the
second one was most level of rotations
while in peacocks still Wild Wings hula
hoop underneath and the third one was
most rotations in the ankle while
hopping
I don't even think I could do one of
those things once so congratulations
Mama the Canada is very proud of you
what was the most difficult one out of
the three would you say
the difficult one would be the
the record
with the one
one cold peacock skill so I have to take
my foot take my leg from the back and
then I had to hold it above my head and
then do a hula hoop in the
need in the leg that I am having on the
ground
so I had to make sure I balanced it not
drop it and make sure my leg is on top
of my head okay I have to know how did
you get started how does one get started
hula hooping
so when I was two years old my mom and
my aunts used to take local classes
so just for fun I took a hula hoop in my
hands and started crying and seeing how
good I was I really wanted to go to the
next step and on and on and since I was
doing it so well that I thought I could
go to the next level and combine
gymnastics with it
so when I combined the combined those
two it was a bit hard but when I kept
practicing I was really good at it and
it was like my talents
so I thought I needed to do something
with my talent and so I thought of
getting records first I tried one and
since that one got approved I did more
and more until now I've reached six
wow you have six World Records all to do
with hula hooping I'm guessing
wow that's amazing and you know some
kids will be watching this I'm going to
show this to my own kids and they're
going to say well she just she just
knows how to do this is that all is it
just Talent
no it's not like this timeline just
comes out of nowhere it's something that
you need to keep practicing to achieve
that's amazing okay what is next for
mammothy vinod what's next for you
my next dream is to participate in the
Olympics representing Canada
in rhythmic gymnastics
with the hula hoop of course and uh
mamathie I I wish you the best of luck
you might not even need it to reach that
next goal thanks so much for joining us
it's been a pleasure talking to you
thank you
just love her confidence that's global
national for this Sunday night I'm Farah
Nasser and on behalf of our whole crew
here I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is this beautiful
sunrise over St John's Newfoundland and
Labrador we love senior Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com Donna will be back
with you tomorrow here on the anchor
desk until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
thank you
[Music]
foreign